well mike rosso
getting the start at second base against
the lefty perez and a full count to the
first man perez faces
from the right side that ball pretty
well drilled and it is out of here into
the bullpen
and opposite field home run for mike
rosso mike prusso to the opposite field
over the short wall and into the raised
bullpen
one better in one nothing raise at
fenway runner at first is ben intended
one nothing raised in the bottom of the
first innings one ball and two strikes
swinging
they're gonna get the runner as well
a strike him out draw now double play
completes the backside of that double
play
vasquez second base is michael chavis
that's a bullet up the middle base hit
vasquez with two down heading into third
he's rounding third he'll throw trickles
toward all play but the run is in
celebrating his 25th he has tied the
game frank brosso who hit the home run
sharkly hit left field line this time
into the corner minnie tindy will have
to make the pick up and bronzo
in at second with a double
and red sox tied at one and here's yadi
diaz a run scoring situation
and third and xander bogarts do up so
bogart's weights righty against righty
curtis's first pitch popped up
in the right field again under retro
moving a couple of steps to his right is
there to make the catch
and that will
retire this time rosso will be next and
red sox have not gotten him out yet
tonight
he's cracked the home run he's also
doubled he has scored both times
nice play in third by aroos he's
he took away what was going to be the
third hit for brasso tonight diving step
by rows gets up fires across picked by
berlin what a play
jonathan aruz the third baseman exciting
play a backhand step as he took a double
away from him to retire the sound let's
see the rays get something
moving here so here is manuel margot
with a runner at first base
the chopper that's a fair ball by third
down into the corner and thomas
will go to third they're going to wave
him home
he will score standing and the race pick
up another ron margot
with an extra base hit to make it a
three to one game it is gonna be brandon
lowe to come up and hit for mike prosso
the one-two pitch again on his way
there's a swing and a line driving to
right field back at it is the right
field of verdugo he can't get it it's
gonna hit off on the warning track and
go over the wall into the seats it's an
automatic double for brandon lau
scoring on the play as manuel mar goes
anita the third base and the raised lead
is four to one and now two-minute
scoring position for yandi diaz
crossing the plate
and the rays
make it five to one i'll tell you what
that that is one of the more
mind-boggling plays that we have seen
there is no chance you're not playing in
i mean there's just that's just a waste
of the throw waste of a play raisel
taken robert stock is the new pitcher
and the bases are full of race now
hunter renfro the one pitch way outside
it gets away vasquez can't get it it
goes back to the wall here comes lau
down from third and he will score the
other base runners advanced 90 feet in
the raised lead is now six to one in the
wild pitch
second and third
and there's a fly ball off the bat of
renfrow that's going to be over the head
offended tindy
reigns will score two more runs both
diaz and meadows crossing the plate and
renfro winds up at second base the rays
make it a six-run inning sykes trying to
grab a couple of runs roduko will be
next
one stroked in a fair ball catches the
short side fence
arrows scampering in to score
oh that is terrible been attending
i think he fell down that's what
happened see what happens from the back
side here
right down the third base line now let's
see
what happens
oh yeah he does he trips still would
have been
jackie bradley jr is one for three that
he would two out in the ninth
cut
baseball by bradley jr and the rays win
this one and the rays
go to 10-8 on the year and stay a game
and a half back in the american league
east